- Bonjour tout le monde!
- Aux grands maux, les grands
la COVID-19 a forcé le
gouvernement de Justin Trudeau à
réagir rapidement.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
devoir aider les gens le plus
rapidement possible.
- Mais pour se faire,
du renfort a été nécessaire.
La taille de la fonction
considérablement augmenté.
CBC/Radio-Canada a appr q qu'on
compte environ 35 000 employés
de plus qu'avant la pandémie;
une augmentation de s s s s s st
un coût : la facture du s s s se
d'environ 4,5 milliards de
dollars en02021.
"On demande au gouvernement
d'en faire davantage, et
ces
"On demande au gouvernement
ces chiffres le démontrent."
Ceci dit, il est d'avis qull
faudra un plan détaillé pour
les années à venir.
- We need a plan.sesesesesesesee
taillent la part du lion :
l'Agence du revenuu u Canada,
responsable des programmes
d'aide, comme la PCU, compte
presque 10 000 Emploi et
Développement social Canada,
responblble des Passeports
notamment, 8500 emplois se sont
ajoutés. Il y a prs s de
2000 postes de plus qu'avant à
l'Agence de santé publique du
Canada; et finininininininininis
bureaux d'Immigration, Réfugiés
et Citoyentété Canada, afin de
gérer les crises en Afghanistan
et en Ukraine, entre autres.
Est-ce udididididididididididid?
ARMINE YALNIZYAN, économiste
- Ca a dépend si vous pensez que
c'était important d'avoir des
dedededededededededededededededu
revenu du Canada nous a donnés.
- Mais d'autres s'interrogent.
Le gouvernement pourra-t-il
tenir le rythme? Ltataille de
la fonction publique fédérale
augmente constamment depuis
l'arrivée au p5.5.5.5.5.5.5.5.5.
Le gouvernement insiste :
soutenir l C Canadiens demeure
sa priorité.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréa